des larmes et des réservistes de l'armée
russe embarquant dans des véhicules
direction le front ukrainien
sur les réseaux sociaux les images de ce
type circulent depuis mercredi au micro
d'un média russe s'est appelé témoignent
je n'ai jamais servi dans l'armée je
n'ai jamais été un conscrit je n'ai
aucune expérience militaire
je vais y aller est-ce que j'ai le choix
si je n'y vais pas je serai poursuivi
une séquence qui illustre le flou autour
de la mobilisation décrétée mercredi par
Vladimir Poutine l'armée russe dit avoir
recruté 10000 personnes sur les 300 000
souhaités par le Kremlin tous les moyens
sont bons pour attirer de nouveaux
volontaires le chef de la Crimée annexé
promettent aux candidats l'équivalent de
plus de 3000 euros chers criméen j'ai
décidé que chaque résident mobilisé est
recevra une aide financière de 200000
roubles payés en une fois il s'agit
d'une mesure de soutien pour nos
combattants et nos familles
l'appel à la mobilisation effraie une
partie de la population alors que des
manifestations ont été réprimées dans
toute la Russie de nombreux habitants
tentent de fuir vers des pays
frontaliers dont la Finlande je suis
réserviste donc j'aurais probablement
été mobilisé n'importe quelle personne
sensée est à la guerre il ne veut pas
tuer ou être tué une réticence sur
laquelle insiste le président ukrainien
vaut le dimmer Zelenski a encouragé la
population russe à se rebeller contre la
mobilisation